[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là est ce que ça te fait
quelque chose de voir l'équipe j'ai un
peu envie de chialer mais justine et non
je voulais te dire un truc je te
gagnerai chialer mais vas tu vois ça tu
me manques énormément dans l'émission
franchement je te le jure et de pleurs
merci tu as un amour tu sais je serai
toujours là pour toi est vraiment là
pour vous et tu sais comme comme tu nous
manques dont l'émission c'est vrai aussi
qu âgé d'à peine six jours et qu'elle ne
te dire la vérité et je vous dis pas bon
la halle et des autres aussi voilà il
manque beaucoup mais de tous ceux qui
ont arrêté tpm p on a franchement nous
les la bande cartonne
on s'amuse comme des fous la seule
vraiment qu'il me manque énormément
c'est toi
[Musique]
10 la seule qui n'a qui n'a jamais été
remplacé équipe
irremplaçable c'est toi payer frère
j'aimerais que vous donnez des petits
conseils quand même à la nos
chroniqueurs à noter explique d'or par
exemple quels conseils vous donneriez
ababacar sall il voulait dire je
n'arrête les divans elle était facile
autorités de la faire quels conseils
vous donnerez à valérie benaïm pour que
sadi sexuelle soit encore plus pimentée
à valérie et une chaudière sage maroc
c'était une pierre sur la digue vous
savez je connais oui pas besoin valérie
bombe apparemment c'est connu dans le
métier ne savions pas ici quels conseils
donneriez-vous à jean michel maire pour
qu'il soit moins lourd et plus drôle
arrêt d'arrêter le métier et quels
conseils donneriez à kelly pour qu'elle
perce dans le monde de la musique mais
de la musique
merci mec là moi je vous adore est ce
que vous n'avez pas quand même
l'impression nous avoir un peu abandonné
l'année dernière en partant cole south
et non pas question
j'adore ce musée ce qui te manque le
plus c'est no en tout le monde
toi jean-luc beaucoup beaucoup non mais
tout le monde va loup jean mifa tout le
monde isa non mais je fais pas feint pas
tous les anciens pardon avec qui on a
grandi bien sûr je pense qu'une
l'émission cette année
si tu la regardes bas c'est toujours
pareil la bonne humeur la folie un peu
d'hystérie des jolies recrues à fait
adorable agathe c'est un super boulot et
qui tient bon ludivine que j'aime
profondément je te connaissais déjà
non mais l'émission est ce qu'elle est
et c'est pour ça qu'elle cartonne
toujours autant faim je veux dire il n'y
a pas de répit l'énergumène l'a toujours
toujours affirmant mortels la ja
ouistiti qui te demande avec quelques
chroniqueurs mois d'avril si un gars
ronny coeur et tu rester en contact et
lesquelles sont le plus manqué donc très
honnêtement je pense que on s'appelle
tous les deux jours c'est vrai mais
voilà elle est restée extrêmement ami
avec cyril mais vraiment vraiment très
très très amis après j'ai eu des
nouvelles de tout le monde ici vraiment
chacun m'a envoyé un texto gentil j'ai
déjeuné avec certains j'en ai vu
d'autres
j'ai vu mon jean luc avec bonheur et
et voilà donc je dirais jean luc et
cyril parce que j'ai dit
alors thierry je t'aime thierry vraiment
mais voici un col on voit la mi temps
voyons tout le temps et que j'aime
infiniment et j'avais ensuite bien très
précieux et bernard montiel
on a préparé un petit magnéto qui
revient sur tes meilleurs moments pour
te dire que tu nous manques
voilà beaucoup si vous comptez khoury
vous vous êtes leur et ensoleillé et ne
manquent pas pour exagérer sa mort il
est conçu ces tennis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laura henno